30-minute workouts 20-minute recipes
10-minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get filled on the app store or google
play hi everyone it's joanna here
today's workout is all about
the arms and apps we want to work on
increasing the strength in your arms as
well as
your core there will also be some
explosive movements to get your heart
rate up
so let's have some fun
let's start with a quick warm-up okay so
let's start with
shoulder rolls just big
and nice shoulder rolls back okay point
your elbows forward
and back and now forward
so this will really help you to increase
the mobility
of your joints big shoulder rolls
forward
and now what i'm going to do is extend
your arms to the side
and continue small arm circles
all right warming up the arms your
triceps your
biceps as well as your shoulders now
back
small circles remember to brace your
core throughout the workout okay
so i don't want your body to be moving
it's just your arms moving
good and now just step right at the edge
of your mat
let's get into inch one to plank so
keep your legs straight slowly inch
forward into a plank
brace your core and slowly
inch back and come back up okay so you
should feel the stretch in the
hamstrings by keeping your legs
straight if this is too much for you you
can bend your knees slightly
as you inch back good
so stretching out the hamstrings
and slowly move back
one more down
and as you get into a plank i want you
to rotate twist to the left
back down twist to the right so brace
your core
final balance left and
right okay good
few more right
good one more left down
right and back into a plank groiners
so take your left leg forward and drive
it back into a plank
right feet forward drive it back and
drop your hips down okay i want you to
really feel the stretch in the hip
flexor
back and down good
so try to get your knees to touch the
floor
back again right foot forward
into a plank one last one
back right
back and slowly come back up
into a standing position good
so there will be a total of three
circuits
and we want to repeat each circuit twice
okay
the first circuit is going to be solely
your body weight
there will be lots of planks okay so the
focus
is to work on the strength of your arms
as well as your core
so let's get down onto your mat
all four exercises will be on your mat
let's get into a high plank position
the first workout is going to be a
push-up
and a full so as you bend your knee and
drive your butt back
feel the crunch on your lower abs
alright push up chest down
and crunch feel the work on your lower
abs
as well as your chest and shoulders
if this is too much for you what you can
do is drop onto your knees
push up and fold
good choose your option
and full i want you to really feel
the stretch feel the crunch on
your abs and then get into a plank
and a push-up good
strong arms one last one and good
drop your knees okay next is going to be
a dwarfing push-up for dolphin push-ups
the focus is really on your front
delts and your triceps one of my
favorite okay
so get into a plank position what i'm
going to do
is pike your butt up push it back and
drive your body forward and
pike your butt up okay so really drive
your body as far forward as you can
chin over your fingers good
drive it forward feel the stretch and
the work on your triceps
and your front shoulders drive it back
push it back and remember
to breathe drive it forward
good back push it up
so we can really work on the strength of
our arms
to get it toned just by using our own
body weight good and now come down
okay next is going to be slightly more
challenging
pike presses okay so what i'm going to
do is again
get into a high plank position
inch your toes forward get into a
mountain
and just give me three pike presses so
reach your head
to the floor and then get into a plank
this is your rest position okay so head
to the floor
feel the work on your shoulders
and plank good one short rest
and back again
rest it out high plank good strong arms
let's go press head down
push your butt up and plank
keep going breathe
and high plank and
just drop your knees shake it out a
little bit if you need to okay
all right the final workout for this
circuit
small subtle movements but you will
really feel it on your core
so get into a tabletop position lift
your knees
off the floor and i want you to just tap
your knees
with the opposite hand okay
so the key here is to raise a core
keep your back flat so do not pike it up
or do not let it swing side to side this
is wrong brace your core
tighten your belly really suck the belly
in and just tap
left and right really small movement
good and remember to push into
the ground tap and just gaze
on to the floor good reach the car
suck it in i know it's shaking but it's
good
keep going feel more
and just drop onto your knees okay
let's repeat the entire second once more
okay so the first workout is going to be
a push-up
and a full choose your option okay
either on your knees or on your toes so
one push-up
full push up
and work on the abs good crunch
push up crunch it in really
drive your butt back and down
nice try to go as slow as you can
drive it back push it and come into a
high plank
and into a nice firm
push-up keep going
give me two more let's go
drive it back one more
and good okay all right next
dwarfing push-up okay so
get into a low plank remember to keep
your elbows firmly onto the ground get
into a
plank position pike your butt up
push into your triceps your front delt
drive your body forward
and push good forward
and now really pick your butt up feel
the stretch
and the work on your triceps and your
front delt
good
keep going i want to see
a nice and high mountain
and just breathe
breathing good
breathe in and breathe out
hike it up
oh my arms are burning and just
drop okay pike presses okay
i'm nice so there will be three pike
presses
and into a plank all right good so let's
get into a high plank
bring your toes slightly forward okay
drive your head down
one two three
shift your body weight forward take a
short rest again drive it back
one two three
and drive it forward good pick it up
one two three if this is too much for
you
you can just rest and join in
okay in a bit good one
two three if you need to get into a
cobra
stretch it out get into a high plank and
let's continue
good one two
three plank and drop
okay very very good oh my god
one final one and you will get a
slightly
longer break all right now let's get on
to all fours right
spread your fingers apart for a firm
foundation lift your knees off and now
let's tap
okay small movement raise your core
gaze onto the floor
keep a neutral spine neutral neck
and tap very good okay try not to shift
your body weight
too much to the left or right brace your
core
suck your belly in feel that squeeze
strong arms strong core a few more
we're almost there team let's do this
less than 10 seconds
tap tap one last one
tap tap and now just
shake it out okay
very very well done that is the end of
the first circuit
take a short break and let's continue
with
the second round
[Music]
for the second circuit what you'll need
is a very light pair of dumbbells i
would say between one
to two kilos each if you don't have any
dumbbells at home
then just grab any water bottle okay
it's good enough
so for the second circuit we will be
working
a lot more on the arms okay the first
workout is going to be a w
extension so what i'm going to do is
place both weights
in your arms with the palms facing out
okay i want you to
stand tall and proud raise your arms up
what i want to do is extend it out and
bring it in
extend it out and bring it in okay it
looks like a simple movement
but with the weights in your arms trust
me this is not easy
this is actually one of my favorite
workouts it's really effective
on your biceps as well as your shoulders
okay
so slow extension hold it bring it back
out and bring it back okay now give me
double one
two bring it back in double
hold it good double and drive it back in
good keep going feel the burn
that's what we want do not stop right
now i want you to
get used to that feeling okay good keep
going extend it out in
one more out and in okay
good job next workout round the world
all right i wish we could travel around
the world right now
okay jokes aside dumbbells down palms
facing forward
what i want to do is keep your arms
straight drive the dumbbell
up okay and
slowly come back down so drive it up
and back down again this workout is
really good for your triceps
as well as your shoulders good so the
goal is to keep your arms as straight as
possible
and use the strength from your arms
to drive the dumbbells back up good
again brace your core okay
with all the exercises you have to brace
your car
so do not use momentum this is wrong
brace your core up back down
and up and back down
one more up and down
good okay few shoulder rotations okay
i know it's burning but let's keep it
that way okay feel the intensity
next it's going to be an l rotation to a
shoulder press okay
so start with your pumps facing forward
drive the dumbbell down
l and press it up okay so it's an
l rotation and a straight
dumbbell press up good
do not drop your elbows okay we want to
work in the arms
we want to work in the triceps your
biceps so keep it high do not drop it
this is wrong up l
press it up good job nice control the
weights as you come down
don't just let it drop control it down
and press it up good job l
and up very good
keep going straight arms
only one to two kilos but you can really
feel the burn
okay my arms are tired okay
final workout for this circuit okay
weighted punches
just like kickboxing okay step your left
leg forward your right leg back
both dumbbells up punch to the front
and keep your arms straight okay this
is not a punch okay if you're doing this
it's wrong straight
extend your arms out twist your body
work on your core
at the same time extend it's not a quick
punch it's a slow punch
because i want you to really feel the
weights in your arms extend it out
straight
and drive it back in a straight line
do not drop your arms down okay straight
line drive it back
twist your torso work on your core
good and back in
simple really really simple movements
but really effective
sometimes just by lifting a little bit
of extra weight
it's going to help you progress in your
workout good job
all right now let's repeat the entire
circuit
once more w extension
stand tall stand proud palms facing in
in a w shape and let's go
out and in okay this is killing
this is killing me man my biceps are
burning my shoulders are burning
extend it out pull it in good extend out
and in okay good so do not go
forward it's to the side and in
good job out and in out and
in now let's go double one
two in one two
in good there you go double
ten more seconds i can feel the burn one
two
good double stay with me keep your arms
high last one more give me one more
and drop it down okay hot work okay
now let's go round the world
dumbbells with the pumps facing forward
okay raise your core stand shoulder
width apart now let's go bring the
dumbbells
up over your head control it back down
really feel the tension on your upper
body your arms control
fight against gravity good up again
fight against gravity don't just let it
drop okay
i want every rep to be a quality wrap
good up point your elbows out
try to keep your arms as straight as
possible
just a slight bend in your elbows okay
good let's do this up
control one more up
and back done down shoulder rolls
all right now l rotation to show the
press this is also
really good to improve on your mobility
so i want you to keep your arms
up all the time okay so now let's start
down up to a shoulder press
our rotation back down control it keep
your elbows
up do not drop your elbows try to keep
your arms in line
with your shoulders good there you go
very good
brace your core stand tall
and press it up
up and press good job
working on the sexy arms
let's kill this let's do this up
strong arms ladies i know we hate to
work on our arms on our upper body
i'm the same but it's really important
okay
let's go strong arms and back down
all right final workout okay left leg
forward
right leg back get into a kickboxing
stance
weighted punches okay remember to punch
in a straight line
and drive the dumbbell back in a
straight line as well let's go
left and right good left
and right okay so you're using
um the power from your torso as well as
the power
from your shoulders to drive it forward
pull it back
good pull it back nice strong
punches look straight at one point okay
it's not this
it's not this it's one target
right in front of you good keep going
twist and twist
very good let's go 10 more seconds
let's finish this circuit strong
and you will get a longer break
give me two more on each side let's go
one more
and good all right take a short break
keep yourself hydrated and we have one
more
circuit to go so stay with me
[Music]
[Music]
this is your final circuit this is going
to be a heat
abs workout okay lots of explosive
movement
to really drive your heart rate up and
to also burn calories
and the focus is going to be on your abs
so we will be working a lot on the mat
all right
so the first workout is going to be in
out tucks
so get into a high plank position what i
want you to do is
hop in hop out it's going to be a small
hop that's because i want you to keep
your legs
straight okay by keeping your legs
straight you will really feel
the work on your lower abs all right
so only 30 seconds work
keep your legs straight hop in and hop
out
try to keep your legs straight as much
as you can and feel the squeeze
on your lower abs good hop out
in and out good push through the ground
keep going small hops focusing on the
abs
good all right the next workout is going
to be two plank jacks
and two mountain climbers okay still in
a plank position
two plank jacks and two mountain
climbers
left and right is one
alright so find your rhythm
two playing jacks two mountain climbers
and out remember to keep your back flat
okay
out and in
back flat last one
and good job okay next
side to side knee tucks all right again
in a plank position
what i'm going to do is hop to your left
back into the middle
to the side and in the middle okay so
again working on your abs
and also with a focus on the obliques
so find your rhythm hop to the side
and back in the plank and to the side
i told you it's going to be an explosive
circuit
so stay with me this is your final
circuit
let's go out and in out
and in that's one more and okay
quickly get back up double
knees okay so what i'm going to do is
step
wide give me double knees change
double knees all right so drive the knee
forward feel the crunch on your core
take this as your active recovery
as well we have been working really hard
drive it in drive your knee forward
and crunch feel the work on your
obliques
twist good one last one
that's one more and now back on
to the floor okay we are not stopping
all right in out tucks into a high plank
small jumps keep a leg straight
small hops feel the work
on your lower abs good
tuck it in and out
okay if you need to you can bend your
knees
slightly but don't bend it too much
straight legs hop in and out
all right oh my god i am dying
but let's finish this together playing
jacks
and molten climbers okay strong arms
let's go two playing jacks mods and
climbers
playing jacks and mountain climbers
drive your knees
in and breathe pace your breathing
keep going
stay with me stay strong
oh my gosh okay side to side
knee attacks okay you can't know by the
way i'm breathing right now
this is not easy if you need an option
what you can do
is just take a step to the side or take
a step to the side
out and bring it in okay this is going
to be
your beginner option if you are strong
if you are with me then let's finish
this strong okay
hop to the side back into the center
side
and center push
into the ground let's go feel your abs
working
feel your obliques and
one final workout guys one final workout
double knees okay left and right let's
finish
this strong double knee crunch okay
drive your knee forward and high up
twist working on your torso good
keep breathing
point okay hands high
keep going plus five more seconds
you're almost there you're almost at
the finish line that's one more
and you are done
very very very well done my heart rate
is going crazy right now
it's at 169 bpm okay
let's not rush to go anywhere let's take
this time to breathe
and really bring your heart rate back
down and let's do
a little bit of stretches okay so again
just like our warm up i want you to give
me
big arm circles really
open up your arms feel the stretch on
your shoulders
if your shoulders are clicking that's
absolutely fine okay
just go slow big circles and now forward
drive it forward
what a strong and intense workout
my kind of workout okay i love the lift
weights
i love to feel strong and at the same
time
i like to keep it intense if you find
that this workout is too difficult
you can always take it a notch down
alright so keep
bring your right arms across
and just feel the stretch on your right
shoulder all right
and breathe and now drop it left arm
opposite arm again feel the stretch on
your left shoulder good job
all right now just spread your arms to
the side
point your fingers down and just push
back okay this will really stretch on
your biceps
and you should also feel a little bit of
stretch on your back so push it down
point your thumbs down all right stretch
it out
good job now let's stretch our triceps
so what i'm going to do is bring your
hands back
okay and just pull your elbows
and feel the stretch on along your
triceps right here
okay bring it back
and if you are flexible you can also
interlace your fingers
and stretch it and now
change the other side okay so right hand
back
and just pull it good job
pull it
and now just slowly drop your arms
release all the tension we have worked a
lot on our arms and our core
just release all the tension and let's
take a deep breath
in together breathe in
out very very very well done
i'm sure your arms are on fire right now
be sure to do this workout consistently
for a strong pair of arms and also
strong core
and don't forget to also check out other
workout videos on my youtube channel
combining with my lower body workouts as
well as heat
workouts and i will see you in my next
workout session
let me know how you felt in the comments
below all the best